Koreatown in Los Angeles is the biggest one in the States.
It's literally a piece of Korea just kind of planted in the middle of LA.
But it's not just Koreans living in Koreatown.
There's a huge Latino population.
There's a huge young professional population...
...that chooses to live here because of its central location.
So, it's really cool to see that interaction between cultures.
If you are a big food person,...
...Koreatown is totally a destination spot you have to come and try.
When the sun goes down, it's a very exciting place.
A lot of people come here to have fun.
Bars are open, karaokes are open.
I love that Koreatown is 24 hours.
You can go and have a mud bath literally at 5:00 AM.